but hey folks there are a couple bright
spots
and one of the bright spots that we're
seeing in the united states today
is that it appears
that the republican party to a tiny tiny
degree appears to be warming up to the
idea
of renewable energy
there was a great op-ed in the hill this
week
where they actually talked about a piece
of legislation
that republicans are pushing in north
carolina without democratic input but
this piece of legislation uh would shut
down five major coal-fired power plants
in north carolina in the coming decade
cutting carbon dioxide emissions and
improving air quality importantly the
legislation mandates the maine north
carolina utility duke energy
securitize the cost of coal retirements
that provision will save rate payers
from paying the retirement costs of
those facilities and is something that
could be replicated in other states
across the country to date only a few
other states have adopted a similar
policy the bill would grow renewable
energy substantially by 4 700 megawatts
over the next decade including from
solar power and offshore wind able to
power millions of homes
so no north carolina is a purple state
and you get a democratic governor and a
republican-controlled legislature but
this bill
was crafted without the input of
democrats
in the state of north carolina
and it actually includes we're going to
close down some coal plants and we're
going to create
renewable energy
and republicans did it on their own
as somebody who has spent 17 years
covering environmental
news
reporting on it writing it investigating
it
i'm almost in shock folks i am almost
legitimately
in shock
because i never thought we'd see the day
honestly truly
17 years writing about misinformation on
climate change coming from the right
writing about fossil fuel donations and
how they're paying off politicians
i i'm i'm so incredibly
inspired by this piece of legislation
and of course we can quibble all day
does it go far enough no probably not
but you know what guys sometimes you got
to take a win as a win
and i'm sick and tired of the all or
nothing types
sometimes even a little progress is
something to be celebrated because you
know what when you celebrate the small
victories and the folks see you out
there congratulating them and applauding
them for doing the small steps do you
know what it encouraged them encourages
them to do
take another step
do it again
do more
and sometimes that's what we need to do
more carrot less stick right
so i'm not going to criticize
this piece of legislation right now
if they can get this passed and they can
shut down some of those duke energy
coal-fired power plants in the state of
north carolina then more power to them
replace it with renewable energy that's
even better
this is a good piece of legislation
and i think we need to be celebrating
that fact we get so few victories
especially for the environment folks
so i think we need to celebrate when
that opportunity arises when it presents
itself
take advantage of it because again we
don't get a lot of this
and hopefully
other republicans around the country
take note
the issue of climate change has been
partisan here in the united states for
too long but ironically it's actually
not that partisan
when you go out to the voters themselves
majority of republicans support actions
to protect the environment
from the effects of climate change
they support renewable energy as do
obviously huge majorities of democrats
and that's the thing like when you go
out there to the people there's not this
same divide that you see in washington
dc that is not representative of the
actual country
so that's where my hope lies my hope
lies in the people
and i think if we continue to applaud
these steps and more and more people do
that
we might just start getting some good
legislation and of course the
infrastructure bill
right that has investments in renewable
we had some republicans vote to support
it
that's a good thing
renewable energy equals jobs for the
united states you know if you want to
look at it not in terms of environmental
impact if you want to look at it in
dollars and cents it makes perfect sense
and it makes a lot of sense as well
celebrate the victories when you can
folks because again
too few and far between